>> When you evaluate the network
that's been trained with drop out,
you obviously no longer
want this randomness.
You want something deterministic.
Instead, you're going to
want to take the consensus
over these redundant models.
You get the consensus opinion
by averaging the activations.
You want Y e here to be the average
of all the yts that you
got during training.
Here's a trick to make sure
this expectation holds.
During training, not only do you use
zero out so the activations that you
drop out, but you also scale the
remaining activations by a factor of 2.
This way, when it comes time to
average them during evaluation,
you just remove these dropouts and
scaling operations from your neural net.
And the result is an average of these
activations that is properly scaled.